good evening everybody thank you very
much for joining us
when the pandemic began we had little
knowledge of this virus
and none about the vaccines and the
treatments we have today so there was no
option but to use government regulations
to protect our nhs and save lives
but those restrictions on our liberties
have brought grave costs to our economy
our society and the chances of our
children
so from the outset we were clear that we
must chart a course back towards
normality as rapidly as possible by
developing the vaccines and treatments
that could gradually replace those
restrictions and as a result of possibly
the greatest national effort in our
peacetime history that is exactly what
we have done
thanks to our brilliant scientists
thanks to the extraordinary men and
women of our nhs
and to every one of you who has come
forward to get jabbed and get boosted
the united kingdom has become the first
country in the world to administer an
approved vaccine
and the fastest major european nation to
roll out both the vaccines and the
booster to half our population
we've emerged from the teeth of the
pandemic before many others retaining
one of the most open economies and
societies in europe the fastest growth
in the g7 last year
and while the pandemic is not over
we have passed the peak of the omicron
wave with cases falling and
hospitalizations in england now fewer
than 10 000 and still falling
and so now
we have the chance to complete that
transition back towards normality while
maintaining the contingencies to respond
to a resurgence or a new variant
as we have done throughout the past two
years we'll continue to work with the
devolved administrations as they decide
how to take forward their own plans
in england we will remove all remaining
domestic restrictions in law
from this thursday it will no longer be
law to self-isolate if you test positive
and so we will also end the provision of
self-isolation support payments although
statutory sick pay can still be claimed
for a further month
if you're a fully vaccinated close
contact or under 18 you will no longer
be asked to test daily for seven days
and if you're a close contact who is not
fully vaccinated you will no longer be
required to self-isolate
until april the 1st we will still advise
you to stay at home if you test positive
but after that we will encourage people
with covid with copied symptoms to
exercise personal responsibility
just as we encourage people who may have
flu to be considerate towards others
it's only because levels of immunity are
so high and deaths are now if anything
below where you would normally expect
for this time of year that we can lift
these restrictions
and it's only because we know
omicron is less severe
that testing for omicron on the colossal
scale that we have been doing
is now much less valuable in pre in
preventing serious illness
we should be proud that the uk
established the biggest testing program
per person of any large country in the
world but its budget
in the last financial year was bigger
than that of the home office and it cost
the testing program cost 2 billion
pounds just
last month alone
so we must scale back and prioritize our
resources for the most vulnerable
from today staff and students in most
education and child care settings will
no longer be asked to undertake twice
weekly asymptomatic testing
and from the first of april we will end
free symptomatic and asymptomatic
testing for the general public but we
will continue providing free symptomatic
tests to those of the highest risk from
covid and
in line with the practice of many other
countries we're working with retailers
to ensure you will always be able to buy
a test
we should be clear
that the pandemic
is not over and there may be significant
resurgences
our scientists are certain that there
will be new variants and it is very
possible that those will be worse than
omicron
so we will continue to protect the most
vulnerable with targeted vaccinations
and treatments and we've bought enough
doses of vaccine to anticipate a wide
range of possible jcvi recommendations
today this includes a new spring booster
which will be offered to those age 75
and over older care home residents and
those over 12 who are immunosuppressed
we will also retain disease surveillance
systems and contingency measures which
can ensure our resilience in the face of
future waves or new variants
and we will build on the innovations
that defined the very best of our
response to the pandemic including
continuing the work of the vaccines task
force which has already secured
contracts with manufacturers trialling
new vaccines which could provide
protection against new variants
today is not the day we can declare
victory over kovid because this virus is
not
going away but
it is the day when all the efforts of
the last two years
finally enabled us to protect ourselves
whilst restoring our liberties
in full
and after two of the darkest grimmest
years in our peacetime history i do
believe this is a moment of pride for
our nation and
a source of hope for all that we can
achieve
in the years to come
thank you very much i think
patrick's going to be chris christie
thank you thank you prime minister first
slide please
uh the first slides are ones which has
been shown before but updated
so the first slide is the number of
people testing positive for covid uh in
the uk uh and as you can see although
the um uh the omicron wave is now going
down it reached an extraordinarily high
peak and the number of people still with
omicron is still very high
and people including elderly and
vulnerable people are still being
infected
next slide please
the number of people in hospital with
kovid in the uk
is again still significant and this is
still in many hospitals providing quite
a lot of pressure
on nhs services but the rates are now
going down and have been going down
steadily
now for some weeks
i think it's important to acknowledge
that as with the last peak
and this in this peak it would have been
considerably higher had people not
listen to advice and been careful
not to transmit to other people where it
was avoidable in particularly to protect
vulnerable people so this is i just
wanted to say this would have been a lot
worse uh without that but this peak was
significant in hospitalizations and
those who say that this is a trivial
disease i think need to look at how many
people were in hospital and still are
going into hospital
with omicron
next slide please
on the other hand fortunately the number
of people who have died
with a positive test for omicron and of
course some of these will not have died
of omicron but many have uh was much
smaller than the previous peak although
every death uh is a tragedy for the
individual and for the families
this is now steadily going down
next slide please
and
as a result of the extraordinary work of
the nhs volunteers and people coming
forward we had a very rapid increase in
boosting uh which
the fact that people were able to take
precautions uh before and around
christmas time bought time for uh for
the boosting of the population and in
particular the boosting of the elderly
and vulnerable population this is
continuing people are still coming
forward for their first second and
booster
vaccinations but that extraordinary
swing
saved many people from going to hospital
and would have saved also many lives
next slide please
i just wanted to make a couple of
comments on the impact of vaccination on
severity
there is no doubt that even with omicron
which is a less severe variant in the
vaccinated being vaccinated
significantly reduces in every age band
the risk of gained hospitalization in
hospital and this is
shown on this graph here and if you look
around the world at countries where
omicron waves are ongoing
and where elderly populations have lower
vaccination rates the rate of
hospitalization is substantially higher
next slide please
i think even more striking is what
happens when we get in to the most
severe patients who go into our
intensive care icu
and what this graph shows up going up to
the age of 70 after that the data
becomes slightly less easily interpret
because of confounding factors but what
you can see is the purple bars
are the people is the proportions
relative to the population who are
unvaccinated
and the very low bars there that you can
see almost invisible are the proportions
relative to the population in people who
are vaccinated
with a first second or booster dose
demonstrating really clearly
that
you can be hospitalized you can go
through icu but that vaccination is a
very substantial protection
next slide please
i'd find like to just make a couple of
comments uh on uh the relative
importance of omicron as a cause of
mortality uh at the moment
and if you this the first way of showing
this
is looking all the way back to the
beginning of the pandemic
and this is showing weekly registered
deaths this is all death this is not
just uh covert deaths and in orange are
the ones where covert is mentioned on
the death certificate
and what you can see is really big peaks
which occurred in the first
and second waves and they prolonged but
much lower peak
in the delta wave due to vaccination
and then you still have people who are
uh dying with cobit at the moment but
the dotted line
the purple line
is the average number of people you'd
expect to be dying at this time of year
and as you can see the total number of
deaths now if you combine omicron and
everything else is now slightly lower
than the average seasonal average you
would expect at this time of year and to
show this a slightly different before i
pass on actually just to point out very
large numbers of people much higher
proportion are dying of other things and
that is a key part of the considerations
for how we need to think about the next
nine months
last slide please
and this is a slightly different way of
showing the same data
and what it shows is the really
extraordinarily large waves of excess
mortality this is for all causes
that coincided with the first second and
delta waves
but actually relatively small uh impact
in fact in rel in absolute terms a
slight decrease relative to the average
for this time of year over the five year
over the years that preceded uh the
the kobe pandemic
so i thought it was just worth
highlighting that
because this does demonstrate that in a
highly vaccinated population with
omicron which is a less severe variant
than previous ones the impact on overall
all-cause mortality has been much more
uh muted in fact essentially not uh
visible compared to the previous waves
now i thought because there are some
changes now i'd just like to make some
additional
kind of forward views about what's going
to happen and then
patrick is going to add a few as well
the first is just to say something about
the omicron wave the omicron wave is
still high
and if you look around the uk we're
still in places we're still between 1
and 20 and 1 in 25 people have got
omicron if they were tested according to
ns data which is slightly backward
looking now the rates are coming down
but this is still a very common
infection
and it is important to
view the next
period when we will still have testing
all the way up to april
and which
changes are happening in fact in steps
people think about this as one big step
this is a gradual steady change
over a period of time as the rates are
going down and as we head into spring
and i think it's important to understand
that context this is not a sudden
everything stops this is a steady move
the next thing it's important to
acknowledge is that we all expect and
patrick will talk more about this there
to be new variants
and some of those new variants will just
disappear but some of them will cause us
significant problems and they could be
either
more vaccine escaping but as severe as
omicron but the net effect would be
actually more people end up in hospital
because a lot of our protections are
from vaccination or it could be more
intrinsically severe because omicron
came from a much earlier variant and
patrick will talk a bit about a bit more
about this
so we could certainly end up with
something which is more uh
more likely to lead to hospitalizations
than normal crime and therefore we need
to be very careful as the prime minister
said and have our both our surveillance
and our uh begin to ramp up with us
and then finally just as the good news
is things are going down as we head into
spring we do have to accept that the
respiratory season next winter and in
subsequent winters it's likely to
combine covid whatever variants are
circulating there
flu and all the other respiratory
problems so
we expect the winters to be tricky even
in the absence of significant new
variants and we again the vaccination
program that jcci will consider
we'll take that into account
and the implications of this are
as we look at the next weeks we still
have high rates of omicron
and
i would urge people in terms of public
health advice and this is very much the
government's position and
that people should still if they have
covered
uh try to prevent other people getting
it and that means self-isolating so that
is the public health advice it would
have been the public health advice and
will be the public health advice for
multiple other diseases if you had
norovirus we would give exactly the same
public health advice so this is standard
public health advice for a significant
and highly transmissible infection
all the things that
people have
done so well and have thought about so
systematically remain important
maximizing ventilation
uh hand washing
and
for the period when there are still
significant numbers of cases at least
using masks in enclosed
spaces with large numbers of other
people
is a sensible way of helping to reduce
the risk to others
as rates go down that that will the the
relative benefit of these kind of things
will change but at this point while the
rates are very high this remains
sensible pragmatic advice which
everybody knows about and everybody can
continue to follow and this is part of
the steady movement towards a new phase
of managing this virus
and we must have three things we must
have good surveillance as the prime
minister said to ensure that when new
variants start to take off when we start
to see new surges we know where they are
and we can respond in a targeted and
rapid way to make sure we deal with them
before they cause significant problems
for individuals and for the nhs
we must have the capacity rapidly to
step up
in terms of what we're doing and we must
be able to protect the most vulnerable
and those really are the critical things
that we need to maintain
even beyond the uh this next few weeks a
few weeks into uh the rest of this year
and the rest of the way that we continue
to manage this epidemic patrick was
going to expand a bit on the issues uh
in particular
around variation
yeah thank you so
very clear this pandemic is not over and
it's carrying on around the world and
we're not out of it here yet
the virus is continuing to evolve
so
every variant is an evolution
and
the virus has got a lot of room to
evolve
and it will continue to do so quite fast
probably for the next couple of years
those changes
will alter the properties of the virus
there is no guarantee that the next
variant
is
as
reduced severity as omicron
it could be the same it could be more
could be less
so as it evolves what it's trying to do
is transmit more readily to grow so that
could be because it has got intrinsic
transmissibility advantage
or it escapes immunity
and the change in severity
is a random by-product
so we expect there to be further
variants and they could be more severe
as chris has said if you look at omicron
actually
with the immunity we've got in the
population
the level of severe illness and death
has been dramatically reduced
and that's the reason across the world
people are beginning to release measures
not just here everyone is beginning to
release measures
but in order to do that safely
there are some things that need to be in
place
the first is it's absolutely essential
to have
a way of detecting it a good
surveillance system
and we're lucky that we have a very good
surveillance system in this country the
ons study
which is a way of picking up across the
population both at a national level and
at a regional level and in different age
groups
what is happening and that detection
system is going to be vital
the second thing that's important
is being able to respond quickly
so the resilience and the ability to
ramp up is absolutely crucial and that
doesn't mean ramp up over months if
something goes wrong you need to be able
to ramp up very quickly
just remember how quickly omicron took
off
that tells you you've got a couple of
weeks to get things back in action
so once you take things off
it's going to be important to know how
quickly you can put them back on again
and to get them back in shape in time to
be able to deal with it
and the third
is throughout all of that
there's a sections of the population who
remain vulnerable at all times and it's
important that they are protected both
in terms of their ability to detect the
illness
the ability to get antiviral treatments
quickly and of course the protection
that everyone gets from vaccination
so detect respond
and protect the most vulnerable is
absolutely crucial during a period of
reducing
the measures that are in place
and being careful about how that goes in
relation to what is an evolving virus
with a period of quite unstable
evolution over the next year or more
these measures are going to be important
to give the safety net and as
an american colleague put it at the
weekend he said you can celebrate when
the sun shining but take your umbrella
with you and i think that's really the
message
good i think i think that sums it up
very well thank you very much let's get
a question from the from the from the
public first nicole from the west
midlands looking at the data it would
appear that covid19 hospitalizations
are currently at a similar level to what
we saw in october 2020 just before we
entered a second lockdown
should we now be putting in place more
measures to protect the nhs
well thanks nicole i'm going to ask
chris and patrick to have a go at that
as well
i will just say that the
the the big difference between then and
now uh nicole is that the uh the
number of hospitalizations is is on a
clear downward trend and the number of
people in icu uh is is as a proportion
of those going into hospital is much
much uh smaller and and you'll have seen
the uh the fatality uh numbers that were
we're seeing which are very different
from what we experienced under uh under
previous waves so it's clear that
omicron is uh is very different and and
and and milder in the way that it
behaves that's one of the reasons uh in
addition to the vaccines uh that we have
uh the high level of vaccine-induced uh
and other immunity that's one of the
reasons we can do what we're doing but
um chris and i completely agree that
obviously the prime minister's answer i
mean i think the two the the three
things of knowledge the first of which
is
it is certainly the case that there are
hospitals in the uk which are still
under significant pressure as a result
of omicron and i think we should be
really clear about that but and this is
the big difference the trajectory the
first big difference the trajectory is
definitely down at the moment and it is
steadily down and has been for some time
a way to go but that is the direction of
travel very different to where we found
ourselves in previous periods and
secondly the number of the proportion of
those people who having entered hospital
then end up in intensive care or getting
into deep trouble and in some cases
sadly dying is a very very much much
smaller proportion as a result of
vaccination which we didn't have uh in
october 2020
and of a less severe variant
thanks gemma from greater london
as a pregnant woman i'm told by the nhs
website that i'm more likely to suffer a
serious illness if i catch covid and in
the third trimester it could also affect
my baby
with the plans to remove cover
restrictions being brought forward what
are the recommendations for women like
me and for the clinically vulnerable
people
for the sake of removing social
distancing and wearing masks are we
effectively being told to stay inside
and remove ourselves from the world
uh
gemma no and i think that
uh what everybody needs to do is make
sure that uh
they treat people who may be uh
vulnerable
in any way uh with the utmost uh
consideration and
uh and and you know we've we've gotta
we've gotta if we if we're
uh symptomatic with any disease you
should you should you should treat
vulnerable people uh with uh
uh
with courtesy and and avoid avoid
spreading it what we also want to make
sure is that people who are cleanly
vulnerable do continue to have access
to
to tests
so that
they can know whether they may have uh
covid and and also get the therapeutics
that they they need
depending on what their and what their
condition is um
it is really clear now that uh
vaccination in pregnancy is a very good
thing to do for you
a very good thing to do for your unborn
baby and new data demonstrating that
it's actually also a very good thing to
do for your newborn baby there is now
data that that shows that it provides
protection for newborns so essentially
it's protecting both you and your baby
and i would really really want to use
the opportunity jenna of your question
to encourage anybody who is pregnant and
has not been vaccinated pleased to do so
yeah that that is a very good book
because there was a while when there was
quite a lot of folklore against
vaccination for uh pregnant women and
that was really not not right at all
thanks very much
laura kunsberg bbc news
thank you prime minister um you are
scrapping free tests for all
but you're telling everybody they have
to take personal responsibility how can
people take personal responsibility if
they may not be able to afford to get a
covered test even if they're trying to
and do you accept that you're giving
scotland northern ireland and wales
really no choice but to do the same
because there won't be additional money
for testing and to sir chris and sir
patrick you know many times you've
talked about how a lack of testing early
on
hampered the attempts to save lives
now there are enough tests but the
government is no longer going to fund
free tests for all i know you've both
emphasized the need for good
surveillance but testing is being scaled
back do you worry that in time
that could prove to be a mistake and
just forgive me prime minister as we've
as you've been speaking president putin
has been talking um could you respond to
his claim to recognize the two um
separatist breakaway republics yes uh
sure so uh so thanks laura look on on on
testing that the only reason and first
of all let's be clear we're not uh
ending it ending uh free lateral flow
tests now uh the there are several more
weeks still to to go we won't we won't
do it until the beginning of of april uh
we can only do that because of the
reasons that uh chris and patrick have
set out the uh the high level of
immunity uh the the relative uh mildness
of of omicron uh the the low level of uh
num the numbers of people in icu uh and
the low mortality we're seeing so that
that's the reason uh we can address
omicron uh in this way but what we will
do is make sure that there will be uh
people who continue to get uh testing
vulnerable uh people will continue to to
have access to testing and uh to
pre-test but the most important thing is
that
and i hope this is the big take out from
this uh
it's the sun is shining but we're
keeping our umbrella as patrick said at
the end of this at the end of his
remarks
we were going to make sure that we
invest in in surveillance and the ons
survey is it really is world-class it's
a matter around the world it gives a lot
of very granular data about uh where uh
cases uh uh uh uh breaking out uh
patterns across the across the uk we
will keep that going we'll keep
observing what is happening because we
want to have uh the the keenest pair of
eyes in the in the crow's nest to watch
for the uh the iceberg in the form of a
new variant and that's that's the thing
that's the thing you've really got to to
test for and uh and the
the big surveillance uh tests of the way
uh to to do that
and
uh
if we see
something like that
then that's the moment to get to uh
patrick's point that's when we ramp up
and we we immediately go uh back to all
the things that we have learned to to do
so we have we'll have a stockpile of
of lfds and lateral flow tests we can we
can make at least some of them already
in this uh in this country we have the
we have labs that will keep going like
the rosalind franklin lab uh mobile uh
testing units and so on so
what we want is
to have a formula of of surveillance
followed by surge uh if if necessary but
we we can only take the
uh the the strategy only adopt the
strategy we're adopting today because of
the success of the of the vaccines and
the way uh omicron is currently
responding and sorry on ukraine um
i
just to say uh
i i gathered just as i came into this
press conference that vladimir putin has
effectively announced that
russia is uh recognizing uh the
breakaway republics of uh donetsk and
lugansk
uh this is plainly in breach of
international law
it's a violation a a
flagrant violation of the sovereignty
and integrity of the
uh of ukraine uh
it is a repudiation
of the of the minx process and the minx
agreements and
i think it's a very
ill omen and a very dark sign
and it certainly does not seem to me
that it's it's certainly
an indication uh yet another indication
uh that things are moving in the wrong
direction in ukraine uh the uk will
continue to do everything we can to
stand by the people of of ukraine uh
with a very robust package of sanctions
as you know uh
fortifying the eastern flank of nato in
all the ways that we have uh but also
being one of the few countries to have
uh given the ukrainians the defensive i
stressed defensive uh weaponry uh that
we think is is appropriate to their to
their needs and we will continue to to
think about what more we can do uh to
support ukraine in what is clearly a
very very dark and difficult time
i know there was a question for
in terms of on the testing um the
essentially three reasons for testing
the surveillance and i think the
intention as the prime minister has said
is to continue surveillance there'll be
some modification to that but the aim is
to have a good surveillance system
because you need that for policy
decisions
the second reason is clinical to guide
treatment expectations continue that in
the nhs uh there are questions about
exactly how we do do this in terms of uh
getting antivirals to the people who
most need them and that's a key decision
that needs to be taken over the next uh
period and then the third reason and
this is the one that is being scaled
back but not yet but will be scaled back
uh is the is using them for control but
as the prime minister said uh as in when
the surveillance shows you need it
what everybody has stressed is there's
the need to be able to stand things up
again if necessary were there to be
something that's severe enough to need
it so it's that third area where the
biggest changes will really occur
i mean i don't think anywhere across the
world where
restrictions are being relaxed
you can have any other view other than
that will increase transmission
so that is
inevitable as you go back to normal life
that transmission risk increases
at the beginning we just didn't have
tests
we've now got tests and fortunately
we've got lateral flow tests which can
be
stored and released very quickly and so
it's going to really have to be this
rapid detection
and response at scale
in order to get testing into the right
place depending on what the
circumstances are and as
chris has indicated at the moment with
omicron i mean it spread very widely it
hasn't caused
huge numbers it has caused some and it
has in other countries caused quite a
lot but in this country hasn't got huge
numbers of very ill people
or deaths
if that changes then obviously testing
becomes more important in the meantime
the testing must be there for people who
need it and that definition of people
who are in that at-risk group is
critical for appropriate use of testing
thanks robert person itv
um a couple of questions on
ukraine the recognition of lugansk and
donya is a clear violation of
international law as you say it's
accelerating the breakup of ukraine
surely this is the moment to introduce
additional
severe
sanctions the time for waiting must be
passed
and on what you've announced today
a couple of questions one is after april
the first
if you get covered will you
isolate
uh secondly
um
you introduced
sorry you you announced today the end
of the self isolation support package
and within a few weeks you won't be able
to get statuses sick pay on day
one
you are making it harder for poorer
people to do what you think is the right
thing which is to isolate if they get
covered
so
fine thanks robert very much so on on
the
um
uh the statutory sick pay issue first of
all and uh and
we will continue with the day one uh
payments uh for the next few weeks uh
but
i think after that what we need to to
recognize is that we're effectively
dealing with a particularly in
vaccinated people with a a disease that
is that is
like norovirus or uh or flu or uh any
other infectious respiratory uh disease
and people should uh
think about how they
interact with others and they should be
uh respectful of other people's health
and
and behave responsibly and that and that
and that goes for any the point i'm
trying to make is that goes for uh for
any uh infectious uh disease which which
you might be bringing into uh into
contact with people who uh who are
vulnerable i think you know in this
country
i've often heard it said over the last
couple of years that we uh we have a
habit of of going back to work or going
into work uh when uh
we're
we're not well
and
people contrast that with germany for
instance who uh where uh
i'm told
much more disciplined about not going to
work if you're if you're sick and i'm
just i'm just suggesting that that might
be the uh
something we could we could learn and as
for me i will i will i will i will
exercise
restraint and responsibility and try to
avoid infecting infecting other people
and on on your um
your point about sanctions
um
look uh
we have to see what exactly has happened
in uh donetsk and lugansk in the donbass
area um
what i have said before
about the package of sanctions is that
they will be triggered with the first
toe cap
of a a russian incursion or russian
invasion
but plainly what has happened is
extremely bad news
and
we will be urgently talking to uh our
friends and allies uh around the world
all of whom are uh
jointly signed up with us in this
package
of sanctions because it is it is i mean
i think you know i think the drift of
your
question is right it is becoming clear
that we're going to need to start
applying as much pressure as we possibly
can because it is it is hard to see how
this
situation uh improves
uh let's go to um
bear through b of sky thank you um
prime minister just to follow up on
ukraine ten days ago at nato i asked you
if you were coming to the conclusion
that president putin actually wants this
war at the time you said i honestly
don't think a decision has been made
what do you think tonight
how has that changed and on
the matter of pavid prime minister
you've spoken about hope tonight and the
country getting its confidence
back
but to sir patrick
uh sir patrick and sir chris
it seems to me that you're clear you're
making it clear that this pandemic is
far from over
what are you feeling are you more
anxious than confident as these
restrictions are dropped and and to the
prime minister
you know we've been doing these press
conferences now on code for two years
covid has dominated your premiership it
put you in hospital it could bring about
your downfall depending on the outcome
of that met investigation and today it
seems that you're trying to turn the
page but would you be satisfied if your
legacy ends up being covered and your
conduct during it thank you uh yeah so
uh
first of all on
uh on on your your your question about
about covered and i think
uh chris and patrick may want to talk
about anxiety look i think that um
the the country as a whole
when you look at the uh
the response to that the government was
able to mount to kovid
and you look at what the country has
done uh i think the two things have
have gone together and i think it's been
quite remarkable if you look at the the
look at the numbers at the back of the
living with covid uh document about uh
vaccination rates uh roll outs uh what
we've been able to do
uh we we were in incredibly fast and
that was a joint work of the of the
british uh public uh and and the
government uh the public were absolutely
heroic uh in what they did
and
um
you know i will be very very proud of
what has been achieved
to be to be frank with you but um
on the anxiety point
i i don't want you to think that there's
some
you know uh
division between uh the the the gung-ho
politicians and the cautious anxious
scientists uh
much they may suit everybody to say so
we we have a
a a very clear view of this this has not
gone away uh we're able to make these
changes now because of the of the
vaccines and the high level of immunity
and all the other considerations about
omicron that you've seen
um
but
we have to face the fact that there
could be
likely will be
another variant uh that will cause us
trouble
but
i believe that thanks to a lot of the
stuff that we've done particularly
investment in
in vaccines and vaccine technology
and and and therapeutics we'll be in a
far better position to tackle uh that
new variant when it comes
and on your question about uh about
putin and you know
i i don't know what's in his mind i
can't read it uh i think the sort of
chance that he uh could roll back from
this and we've got to we got to pray
that that's the case
in terms of uh anxious or confident
when i come from a profession which
tries to train you not to be either of
those things and to go between the
middle
and just have a plan and be steady about
it say these are the facts this is the
plan this is what we're going to do we
will execute the plan and we hope that
we can go steadily in the right
direction
so that's very much the way i hope that
we can think about this and present this
so neither of the extremes
so i mean just to quote again the same
american i quoted earlier on he said
this weekend the one thing that this
virus has taught you is not to be cocky
yeah so i think we just need to go very
carefully we need to monitor carefully
and be prepared to react
and the other thing that i think is
clear which is important to bear in mind
throughout we said this right the way at
the beginning
this virus feeds off inequality and it
drives inequality and that needs to be
born in mind at all times doing this
um martin brown the express
thank you prime minister you've spent
much of the last two years
urging people
to work from home to help fight against
covid um as we move into this next phase
and with the economic recovery in mind
what is your message uh to those people
who are still reluctant to return to
their workplace
and then what more should employers be
doing to get their staff back
well thanks very much martin look i i've
i've always been a believer in uh
the importance of people getting into
into work particularly for younger
people who need to build up social
capital and understanding of
of their of their jobs their professions
and their place of work and i think it
is it is invaluable i think if people uh
try to do everything remotely they will
they will miss stuff out and so i would
i would encourage people they will they
will they will lose out and i would
encourage people to uh to get back to
work with confidence i think you know we
have we have the right now we have the
grounds now uh to be confident and we
should uh we should be confident
i think that was it wasn't it
thank you brilliant thank you thanks
martin uh dan bloom the mirror thank you
prime minister um
you've just talked about asking people
to exercise personal responsibility even
to break the habit of going into work
when you're sick but you're also
scrapping day one statutory sick pay the
500 payments
so just to be clear are you saying that
a low-wage worker
who has covered should stay at home even
if they're not going to get paid can you
look people who voted for you in the
eyes and tell them that that is an
acceptable situation
and to the scientists so chris and sir
patrick
uh two questions will you both continue
taking natural flow tests
uh beyond april if you're going to a
crowded gathering like the pub or
something like that
and are you satisfied that the plan
announced today will
not lead to a rise in long covert and
will keep immuno suppressed people
safe enough
thanks
thanks thanks very much dan well look
we want to make sure that uh and i i
echo what what patrick just said uh just
now about the the inequalities of of
kobe and that's why we've done
everything that we can throughout the
the pandemic to support people on uh on
low incomes uh who've uh who've been
having it uh tough uh with with
huge investments in uh in hardship funds
uh
increasing the uh the living wage all
the all the contributions that we've
made and and what we're doing now to
tackle the uh the cost of living uh we
we totally totally get how how difficult
it has been
i think that the
it is it is still sensible uh for people
uh to avoid spreading covid uh and
indeed any other uh dangerous
respiratory disease and i just you know
go back to what i was saying earlier on
i think i think maybe
we can we can learn something about the
advantages of of not spreading uh
disease statutory sick pay uh is there
and also of course people are entitled
many people
are entitled to other uh forms of uh pay
i know that won't be everybody uh dan
and i understand that but for those
people who don't get uh enough support
uh we're trying to make sure that they
they get it uh in other ways and they
get uh helped uh in in tough times uh
through other through other support
we're giving through through local
councils or or by other routes
in terms of uh the
um current situation i mean i'd like the
prevalence to be lower the rates of
infections to be lower and um
the sage advice it's all in the public
domain
shows that
roughly somewhere between 20 and 40
percent reduction in transmission
because of our current behaviors and
we're not back to pre-pandemic behaviors
yet and as those return you would expect
the pressure on transmission to increase
so there's something about cautious
behavior which remains there's
definitely the public health advice on
isolation if you are
positive with covid
and i want to just re-emphasize the
value of vaccination and the
long-covered point there's now evidence
that the vaccines don't just protect
against infection and against severe
disease but they also reduce long covert
so there's a very very strong reason for
everybody to be vaccinated
get up to the first dose second dose and
third dose and of course for the
immunosuppressed it's going to be all
the people who are particularly
vulnerable they may need another vaccine
at some point to get that up and that
they need access to
antivirals and they do need the access
to testing in order to be in a position
to be treated quickly so i think there's
a series of things that need to happen
to keep everybody safe
during what is inevitable which is the
world at some point needs to start
returning to normal behaviors
will you carry on taking them even if
you have to pay
sorry
why didn't i do that one because i
completely agree obviously with
patrick's other comments and i think
there are three things
that i will be trying to think about
first question is how common is covered
at the moment if it's very high
absolutely that increases the
probability
second is the environment you're in if
you're an environment where you're
outside a long way from other people
then the risks are so small it probably
makes no difference if you're in a
crowded environment absolutely and the
third and probably the most important
one and it builds on what patrick's just
said is if i'm mixing with vulnerable
people uh if i was going to see an
elderly relative if i was going to
go to a
let's say hematology board in a hospital
of course those are the kind of
situations i would want to minimize the
risk to other people because the whole
point about the lateral flow is about
minimizing the risk to other people
thanks very much kevin scofield half
post
thanks prime minister um are you not
simply adding to the cost of living
crisis from april the 1st and people are
looking at higher national insurance
payments uh higher energy bills
rise inflation rising interest rates and
from april the first they're now going
to have to pay probably about 20 quid
for a box of lack of floor tests is that
not simply adding to the cost of living
crisis that people are already
experiencing and you talk about personal
responsibility people having to take on
more professional responsibility now
isn't that slightly hypocritical when
you're under investigation and from the
police
for allegedly breaking your own lockdown
rules and to the scientists and public
messaging has been very important
throughout the pandemic and tonight
you've said that the pandemic isn't over
and that future variants could be more
serious uh than what we've seen
previously but at the same time
uh self-isolation rules are ending and
we're getting rid of free tests is there
not a danger that we're sending mixed
messages to the public and they might
simply just switch off
um so uh kevin first of all i can't i
can't comment on the allegations that
you refer to as a
as i've said before we'll have to to
wait and see on that but i think the the
point remains uh very very important
that we're moving away from uh from
legal compulsion to uh to personal uh
responsibility but
on your on your point about um
cost of living and
uh
just go back to where we were
this this
um
uh
change in the testing regime won't come
through for for a few weeks to come by
which time uh we i hope and expect that
the incidents will have further uh
declined
um
and
so i i hope that uh the impact on people
will will be will be will be minimal but
what we're also trying to do
is abate that go deal with the cost of
living uh crisis in the most important
possible way and that's with uh helping
people with universal credit uh with
lifting the living wage but above all uh
getting them back into work
uh with
better paid jobs and we by the way which
would not have been possible if we
hadn't had uh the
openings up we had in uh in the summer
uh and and if we hadn't been able to
keep going uh throughout
christmas and new year and it's that
it's that
strength of the economy that is the
single best protection uh for people uh
the single the single best thing that we
can do as a government uh to help them
tackle uh the the cost of living and
that is is of course being made possible
by uh the the uh
the vaccine rollout and and the way
people are pulled together
when public messaging uh is is important
obviously um
it's much more difficult uh practically
as someone who's trying to do it when
there's a transition than when you're
giving the same message day in day out
so
you know we have to accept that we're
going through a transition and an
appropriate transition
and that
does mean we need to change the way we
think about things and that needs to
communicate as clearly as we can and we
do our best uh to do so we don't always
succeed perfectly
but i would make sort of a general point
on the point about mandation which is an
issue absolutely for politicians and
parliament
and public health advice they are
separate things there are very few areas
of public health
which we give advice on which actually
are subject to mandation so it is a very
atypical situation what what's happening
is in a sense this is reverting away
from an abnormal situation to a much
more normal one that doesn't mean the
public health advice actually changes in
terms of what in broad principles we
think people should do and i'm not going
to repeat them i said them right at the
beginning but i think it is important
that people realize this is a steady
change this is not a sudden
move of course you announce changes at
particular points in time but actually
what the prime minister has laid out
is essentially a stepped series of
things and the ability to keep looking
at things so that if there's a change in
the environment then we can at that
point respond to that change and i would
just refer you to again to some of the
sage papers released last week that
looked at this question about
consistency of messaging and the point
that now it's
health professionals nhs chief medical
officer
local directors of public health
that's where the clear consistent
messaging is going to come from as chris
said which is the advice that comes in
rather than legal mandation but that
needs to be clear and consistent and
aligned with overall government
messaging as you say
thank you everybody very much i'm just
going to talk to president zielinski of
ukraine and offer him the support of the
united kingdom thank you